these people we keep hearing from
uh who uh chase barry weiss out of the
new york times
who chase suzanne moore out of the
guardian in the uk
uh who who cry when they learn that a
new jordan peterson book is going to be
published and pay their salary the next
year
this is a generational thing and i don't
know at this stage that we can say it's
completely a political movement it's
some kind of counter revolution that has
been going on
it believes as you know that speech is
harm
and harm is not harm but silence is
violence and violence is fine
it has a set of mantras and i simply
think it won't
stop until it it hits
the reality of this life
it seems to me that something very wrong
has happened with your media
uh not just the broadcast media but the
print media uh
it's it's um i don't get stuck on it but
i mean
every country i know about i know the
new york times and can prove that it's
lying
so i can't read it because any country i
don't know very much about
i would i would assume that they're
lying but i wouldn't know exactly how
um so so you've got a very
deep problem in your legacy media
and uh obviously a lot of people have
been pointing that out for a long time
um and i wonder now if if trump does go
those those papers and magazines will be
in want of an enemy
and uh often as you know that's that's
the worst thing for a person is if they
lose their enemy
um but yes we we we don't have that many
problems
the the the problem we do all have it
seems to me and you've written about
this as you just
you know about it as well as anyone is
that people have become very bad at
listening to a country opinion
and that is i think that's going to
prove to be a generational thing
that there just is uh i speak 24 hours
after
the news came out of jordan peterson's
publishers in canada that there had been
wailing gnashing of teeth actual tears
here's
at the at the staff meeting when some
some employees of uh it's painful
uh penguin uh uh the the the some of the
employees of penguin discovered that
they were gonna
uh publish another book next year by a
man who's actually earned them their
salaries
quite literally he sold probably about
seven million copies last i heard so he
floats
in many ways the entire ability for them
to to choose all these other
books that aren't going to do quite as
well
yeah yeah it's only because of him that
they can publish the sort of
intersectional fictional
team list um yeah no these um
but this these people we keep hearing
from
uh who uh chase barry weiss out of the
new york times
who chase suzanne moore out of the
guardian in the uk
uh who uh who cry when they learn that a
new jordan peterson book is going to be
published and pay their salary the next
year
this is a generational thing and i don't
know at this stage that we can
say it's completely a political movement
it's some kind of counter-revolution
that has been going on
it believes as you know that speech is
harm
and harm is not harm but silence is
violence and violence is fine
it has a set of mantras and i simply
think it won't
stop until it it hits
the reality of this life i don't know
when that'll happen i just hope it
happens
very very soon i think that everybody
who cried
at the meeting i said this this morning
on social media everybody who cried at
the meeting and said that they didn't
want to be at the publishing house that
published jordan peterson
bang out next morning your job is
advertised so many smart young men and
women
should be in the publishing business in
heaven and have a very
very good reason to be so and could be
excellent in their chosen profession
and they're not because these people who
have no right to be in a publishing
house or in it
and and and clogging up and making
everyone stupider
and so the these people there has to be
fun
we have to make sure that media
companies and others are not held
hostage
by the stupidest youngest most ignorant
people in the room
but is the biggest problem there that
these companies once they fall under the
spell i mean you wrote a book about this
but once they fall under the spell they
bring in the diversity and inclusion
department their hr department
is teaching people to watch out for
white supremacism and all of these
things
thus they they destroy their own
entities i'm completely with you and and
i run businesses if i had employees that
were
upset with me over my decision making
goodbye goodbye that's it
you know but but isn't that the the
bigger problem that once you've let this
thing in
in many ways you're the people you're
the very people you'll let the bad guys
in and now they're in the house running
around yes and what can you do
well what you can do is to reassert your
rights as an adult
what i see everywhere in america in
particular is the
complete retreat of the adults let me
give you an example
i'm sure you've heard many times i
thankfully nobody has actually said it
to my face
or they'd have it coming to them but i
have heard a lot of people
told in recent years educate yourself
everybody who says educate yourself
in my observation is without exception
the
diminished person i have seen speaking
they have no right to go around
being the stupidest person in the room
telling
everyone else to educate themselves they
don't mean
educate yourself they mean agree with me
or else
well here's a suggestion the adults say
no you do not know anything
you're 23 you've got a totalistic view
of the universe that you're going to
discover quite soon at some point in
your life is wildly wrong
and you are making yourself unemployable
here
is your unemployment form your jobs up
for advert tomorrow
that's what the adults have to do i'm
fed up by the way of see
if so ceos and heads of companies and
all sorts of things
ever since the madness of crowds came
out i find that they sidle up to me they
whisper up to me and tell me that this
is what they have
and i'm fed up with the whisperers and
the seidlers
i'm fed up with the adults the people at
the tops of their careers
all of whom are bowing down it's like
that video that went viral the other day
of this you saw this weird lgbtqia
possible kidney thing yeah yeah the kid
based yeah
they're bowing down and worshipping the
new
god thing which is
the stupidest person in the room
and i'm not up for the opportunity cost
societally that that
involves um and i think nobody else
should be either
and i'm i'm fed up of the grassy i'm fed
up of conservatives grousing about it
but this is the stuff that
we've been talking about for years so it
is nice you
you you and i and many other people we
write books about these things we
we can write columns we can do shows
about it and all of that stuff and then
we get what i think
you just said is the most frustrating
part which is people at companies and
people in their own private lives who
are just
still simply afraid to do anything so
then they'll oh douglas i love your book
but i don't want to take a picture with
you or you know something like that like
you're still too out there and too scary
that that in many ways
is the is the most frustrating part
don't you think
uh well i think they usually love photos
anyway yeah no no
they just don't want to post them on
facebook
what i find is uh that
they don't realize that what they are
what they are bringing in is mental and
moral asbestos
they don't realize that it's toxic to
everyone in the atmosphere who has to
breathe it
the job of the adults is to strip the
moral and
mental asbestos from the building as
fast as
possible and if that means stripping
a whole load of under 30s out
then fine there are a lot of very smart
under 30s who could fill those positions
and would do a great and
nobler job at it but it is absolutely
incumbent upon people
as you know it's what i argue in the
madness of crowds to understand
that that is what we are dealing with
once you play the diversity and equity
game
you are infusing the lungs
of your employees with this asbestos
and you have to get it out now if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell